bonjour christian jacob bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être ce matin sur lci au
lendemain d'une interview qui va faire
date sans doute peut-être vous êtes
président du parti et l'air vous avez
mené tambour battant la primaire vous
avez votre candidat et en ce début de
janvier vous êtes évidemment à
l'offensive cette interview ça n'est pas
une interview précisément c'est un
entretien face aux lecteurs du parisien
il ya un passage qui écrase tout parce
qu'elle est trop longue c'est une un
entretien fleuve le passage de moulis
une toute petite partie des français es
réfractaires à la vaccination dit
emmanuel macron commente on la réduit
pardon de le dire comme ça en emmerdant
encore davantage moi je ne suis pas pour
emmerder les français est bien là les
non vaccinés j'ai très envie de les
emmerder j'ai très envie de les emmerder
c'est clair c'est cash c'est une
stratégie revendiquée contre les non
vaccinés l'opposition est vent debout
depuis la publication cette interview
que les problèmes le problème c'est que
c'est d'abord un un acte de faiblesse de
la part du président vous savez
l'insultent ses larmes des faibles quand
vous n'êtes plus capables d'argumenter
quand vous n'êtes pas capables de
défendre vos positions vous réfugier
dans l'insulté ou dans la violence
d'ailleurs le président de la république
lui-même on avait tiré les conséquences
souvenez vous de son interview je crois
que c'était le 16 décembre dernier on
lit d'hitler ne doit pas on ne doit pas
blesser les gens et je ne referai plus
çà et là et retombe dans son penchant
son penchant naturel qui te réfugier
dans la provocation dans l'insulté parce
que la réalité c'est que ce implosion
faible qui ne s'est jamais choisir de
deux choses l'une soit la vaccination
est obligatoire et la loi décide qu'elle
est obligatoire pour tous et à ce moment
là chacun se soumet à la loi soit elle
ne l'est pas et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
la préparation le projet de loi qui
était proposée par le gouvernement ne
rompt pas la vaccination obligatoire et
à ce moment là on ne peut pas avoir un
président de la république dont
l'objectif ça doit être de protéger les
français l'objectif ça n'est pas dormir
dès les français quand elle n'est ce pas
les français île en mer et non vaccinés
s'ils vous permet la prise à gordes 5
million trois cent mille français
aujourd'hui qui sont n'aurait qu'une une
partie des français
de manière provocante et blessantes il
le fait pour ça et encore une fois c'est
quand on est faible quand on sait par gu
mentez vous savez c'est comme un enfant
lorsqu'il pique une colère qui lancent
ces jouets etc c'est parce que ben il
sait plus argumentée donc un peu de sang
froid n'est sur le président mais elle a
un peu de sang froid sur le vous le
savez bien c'est précisément pas une
petite phrase jean pascal à sarkozy
c'est pas l'enfant qui pète un câble
comme on dit parce que c'est réfléchi
c'est une stratégie et la stratégie
chimiques c'est d'autant plus si c'est
d'autant plus cynique moi je suis pour
le pass vaccinale j'ai toujours dit je
les dis encore hier dans l'hémicycle
mais on ne peut pas avoir un président
de la république
encore une fois qu'ils se réfugient de
cette manière dans l'insulté dans la
provocation il est là il ya ce côté père
de la nation il doit rassembler et on
doit avancer par la contrainte et de
façon en faisant soral parfait petit à
petit effectivement qu'on arrive à une
vaccination générale je suis favorable à
la vaccination sur la forme il invoque
sans le dire évidemment georges pompidou
qui en 1966 avait dit arrêtez d'emmerder
les français
faut arrêter avec
foutez leur la paix c'est moins de
sassafras mais c'est le même vocabulaire
qui n'en n'ont menacé c'est précisément
de lentilles pompidou c'est exactement
le contraire
pompidou s'était arrêté dans merdé les
français lassés j'ai envie de les
emmerder et je vais continuer les
emmerder c'est quand même à vos
différents et ce qu'ils disent et les
non vaccinés oui oui oui romain journée
aujourd'hui mais oui mais c'est à chaque
fois la même chose vous savez ce
président était incapable de faire
incapable et à chaque fois sanitaire
il appelle pas sanitaire nous avons voté
le passé ni terre à l'assemblée
nationale on s'est abstenu en première
lecture maintenant que bien sûr mais il
était votée à l'assemblée nationale
c'est pas le monarque j'ai fait non
c'est pas ça il ya encore
on est encore dans une démocratie il ya
parlement enfin bref
au delà de au delà de cela
voyez par exemple sur les dépenses les
dépenses publiques jamais les dépenses
publiques avant le quotidien entendu
avant la qu'ovide non explosées autant
que ce où que ce soit emmanuel macron il
fait même plus que françois alors on va
parler de votre programme et parce qu'il
a fallu à passer mais sur le fond mais
ne s'est pas réformer n'est pas alors
sur le fond ans christian jacob
j'entends bien votre critique sur la
forme
est déjà sur le fond vous l'avez
esquissé mais là il ya une stratégie
c'est de conduire les non vaccinés à la
vaccination
c'est ça son pari non qu'est ce que ça
peut être productifs est ce que ça peut
être efficace parce que l'enjeu est
important crois pas que ce sera efficace
il pousse à la radicalisation des
extrêmes l'hystérie et et les dents une
dans une logique de faire monter les les
voix les plus extrêmes donc il est dense
et il est dans la logique de faire
monter les positionnements les plus
extrêmes et le but de la provocation
c'est bien ça ils cherchent à
radicaliser comme à chaque fois avec
avec emmanuel macron c'est de toujours
diviser opposer les français les uns aux
autres alors voyez sur le ce texte on
pouvait arriver à un consensus
globalement dans tous les gros noms
parce que là écoutez honda christian oui
alors la question est très importante
c'est quelles conséquences maintenant
sur ce texte qui voulait instaurer le
pass vaccinale le 15 janvier est-ce que
d'abord il va aboutir est ce que vous
êtes favorable à la reprise des débats
oui il faut que les débats reprennent
que je ne sais pas quoi mais mais mais
je ne sais pas s'ils vont reprendre
cette nuit à vous à une au président oui
non mais bien sûr mais cette nuit une
heure et demi d'interruption de séance
entre minuit et une heure et demie du
matin parce que les ministres entre eux
excusez moi d'être aussi triviale que le
présent la république s'engueulent
entrevue avec le premier ministre et
sont incapables de décider ce que si ça
doit reprendre ou par référendum en faut
rappeler que vous demandez une partie
d'opposition la présence de jean castex
qu'il ya eu des conciliabules finalement
il n'est pas changer quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui viennent bon je pense que
je serais permis de pouvoir reprendre
sereinement au moins à condition qu'ils
s'en explique nous nous souhaitions
savoir une explication bien sûr après
une interview comme celle-là a minima
doit y avoir une explication et le
président lui-même doit reprendre la
parole pour expliquer vous demandez quoi
des excuses des cupides où il doit
s'expliquer est-ce qu'il est là protégé
les français wisques déjà pour reprendre
corps une fois cette expression pour les
emmerder ici c'est un sens je les
protège je protège canon vingt dix pour
ces français qui sont vaccinés oui mais
vous savez très bien que non d'ailleurs
lui même on a tiré les conséquences
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est lui qui
fait à tf1 une interview pour dire je ne
ferai plus ça il ya quinze jours et ont
dénoncé pas ya trois mois il ya six mois
yade il ya deux ans il ya 15 jours
quatre jours après ils reviennent ils
retombent dans son penchant naturel dans
ses penchants naturels caractériser les
toits par l'incapacité de faire est ce
que vous avez dit
ça il veut faire le pass vaccinale est
ce que vous allez voter non mais le plr
je suis favorable au pass vaccinale je
les dis dans l'hémicycle avec beaucoup
de clarté parce que je pense que la
solution c'est la vaccination
en revanche ce n'est plus l'époque on va
lier - médiation valérie pécresse il à
s'abstenir
c'est ici on posera pas voilà on ne
s'opposera pas de tout tu as attendait
le s'est divisée nom des plaies d'abord
la majorité est divisée
la réalité c'est ça non mais le
gouvernement présente un texte nous on
n'a pas été associée au texte le
gouvernement a préparé seul son texte il
est incapable aujourd'hui de rassembler
sa majorité
sa propre majorité c'est ça son sujet ça
n'est pas le nôtre la majorité absolue
le gouvernement là et donc il a besoin
de nos voix parce qu'il est incapable
d'avoir une majorité vous lui donnez moi
je veux toi devant leur excellent je
peux vous le redire au bout et la
majorité de jeux vote mais bien sûr mais
le poussoir haxhinasto posera pas ou
presque vaccinale gallisa mans et il
sera adopté pour une application que
j'écoutais ça c'est le gouvernement qui
fixe l'ordre du jour déjà faut qu'ils se
mettent d'accord entre eux est-ce que le
premier média s'expliquer ou pas je vous
dis une heure et demie hier de
conciliabules entre les membres du
gouvernement on n'y est pour rien c'est
eux qui sont après les propos du
président de la république qui suspendu
découvrir dans la presse comme nous hier
soir
conciliabules entre matignon l'assemblée
l'elysée tout le monde ce téléphone se
voit et pendant une heure et demie on ne
fait rien parce que parce que sur
incapables de se mettre d'accord entre
eux la veille c'est vous qui aviez
interrompu les débats c'est vous qui
aviez fait en sorte qu'ils sont
interrompues non non débat non non non
non je sais pas c'est pas nous qui avons
demandé à lever le veut nous avez vous
avez refusé que les débats se prolonge
l'un d'eux une heure du matin par un
vote ah bah oui position à bâle dont
bien sûr oui m'enfin je pense que
honnêtement
légiférer jusque 5h 6h 7h du matin ça
n'aille qui fait alpha oui mais ça n'est
pas sérieux ça paraît wilson et oui mais
d'accord mais est ce que c'est ça la n 9
récente dit non quand amine ben oui bien
sûr 160 mais qu'est ce que ça change
attendait nos sages accepte pas ce
qu'est ce que ça change le texte il est
prévu pour être adopté le 15 janvier
est-ce qu'il soit adopté cette nuit à 7
heures du matin ce matin 7 heures du
matin ou demain ou après demain ça
change quoi pour le 15 janvier ça change
rien simplement il faut travailler dans
des conditions sereines et conditions
sereines c'est qu'on lève les séances à
une heure du matin l'assemblée ouvre à 9
heures le matin se termine à une heure
du matin voilà vous dites ça sert à rien
d'y passer la nuit une question quand
même vous l'avez sans doute entendu
comme moi une infirmière un soignant qui
regarde ce que vous avez fait à
l'assemblée
avant-hier soir dans la nuit c'est à
dire de retarder les débats et eux ils
se battent en réanimation ce disant il
faut absolument absolument se passe
vaccinale ou en tout cas un outil pour
pousser les ans avec ces nations
comprenez qu'il ne vous comprennent pas
ils se disent mais à quoi ils jouent
non mais met d'accord bétourné vous
m'aidiez se tourner vers le gouvernement
elle je peux pas vous dire plus sommes
favorables on ne s'opposera pas max
passe l'accident et moi je dois en f1
tout comme individuel je l ona le coût
politique les noms mais le football ici
mais le coût politique attendait cette
interview ridicule et provoquant néfaste
aux en fait bah oui d'abord à pose un
problème aux gouvernements jeudi qu'ils
sont incapables de se mettre d'accord
entre eux c'est d'abord ça le sujet ils
sont d'accord pour combattre oui enfin
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas si le premier
ministre devait revenir s'ils devaient
parisien s'explique je mets les enjeux
c'est la vaccination
y sommes favorables je ne peux pas vous
dire plus vous aimez femmes favorables à
la vaccination obligatoire moi je leur
ai dit tout à l'heure comment on fait
pour la vaccination obligatoire sinon
j'utilise tue pas dit que j'étais
favorable à la vaccination non à la
vaccination obligatoire moi je considère
non mais je considère que le vaccin est
la seule solution est qu'il faut
effectivement avoir une vaccination
générale et je pense que par le passé
vaccinale on y arrive mais on n'a pas
besoin d'aller provoquer d'aller
insulter les un réseau regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec les gilets jaunes à
coude insulte voilà à quoi on arrivait
edouard philippe et emmanuel macron
avait réussi à mettre le feu sur tous
les ronds-points de france est alors pas
par les provocations par les insultes
pourquoi
complexe car c'est une déclaration ya un
sujet de fond aussi christian jacob il
ya quand même il vous constatez il ya un
fossé qui se creuse entre les non
vaccinés qui sont minoritaires mais
enfin qui sont comme ça il y en traçant
et les vacciner et à sébastien huyghe
que vous connaissez bien députés aient
l'air qui avait déposé un amendement
pour que les soins en cas de vide soit
remboursée avec une franchise pour les
non vaccinés oui c'est l'idée que l'idée
que développe emmanuel macron même
silence vocabulaire il pousse très loin
c'est il faut les rendre responsables de
leurs joueurs mettaient de le dire
sébastien huyghe le fait beaucoup plus
intelligemment que le président de la
république
moi ça ne me choque pas alors après il
faut monter le niveau de la franchise
mais effectivement il faut aller vers
une incitation à la vaccination jeunes à
la vaccination pour moi est la solution
peut-être que demain il y aura d'autres
autre possibilité de stopper répétées
contre l'adoption de cet amendement rend
pas il faut regarder à quel niveau le
mec se dira titre est soutenu non non
mais mais simplement
il faut à chaque fois dans ces périodes
de tension trouver la capacité à
rassembler et à ne pas fracturée moi ce
que je retiens en tout cas c'est que
vous président ait l'air vous êtes un
arbitre du jeu politique vous dites que
il faut adopter le pass vaccinale que
c'est possible d'y arriver pour une
application au 15 janvier vous attendez
de voir si effectivement il ya voyez par
exemple sur les fonds sur les sur les
enfants on a fait évoluer les choses
avec le m en tiens d'ailleurs c'est à la
fois d'autres positions mais aussi d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires de la
majorité de relever le seuil de 12 ans à
16 ans pour les enfants ils ne sont pas
soumis aux passes vaccinant saliver il
garde le patois long terme et on passera
à 16 ans donc on est dans une attitude
constructive
pas toujours lisible avant-hier on ne
savait plus si vous étiez pour non
respect mais faux accident mais mais
faut accepter de débattre face de dire
c'est pas l'aide si si on ne débat pas
l'assemblée et bien c'est le feu dans la
rue et le président de la république
préfère mettre le feu dans la rue plutôt
que d'avoir à débat politique serein à
propos de lisibilité le président
revient aussi dans cette longue
interview sur la polémique drapeaux
européens elle a été disproportionnée et
malvenue j'aime l'europe dit il parce
que c'est un projet de paix mélanie
pécresse votre candidate a été une des
premières après marine le pen a fustigé
la décision de ne mettre que le drapeau
européen sous l'arc de triomphe elle
n'aime pas l'europe va bientôt cauchy
bien sûr que si simplement est ce que
demandait valérie pécresse c'est comme
l'avait fait nicolas sarkozy au moment
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne d'avoir et le drapeau
européen et le drapeau français nous
sommes d'or en quoi est-ce que la seule
présence du drapeau européen de latin à
l'identité frais parce qu'on est sous
l'arc de triomphe le tout un symbole et
et on reste français et on est français
on est attaché à notre pays par ailleurs
nous faisons partie de l'union
européenne et donc il pouvait très bien
si président de la république cherchait
un symbole qu'il y ait les deux drapeaux
qui flottent comme si vous venez dans
mon bureau j'ai les deux drapeaux le
drapeau faïza le drapeau européen
beaucoup ont dit c'est une polémique
inutile est ce que la france en tant que
nation était fragile lisez parce cette
décision qui devait durer toute façon de
façon non mais comme à chaque fois un
malaise mais le président de la
république cherche à chaque fois sans
souci c'est de ce n'est pas de faire ça
n'est pas de réformer ça il en est
incapable
mais c'est de savoir comment on peut
provoquer comment on peut être sûr des
petits actes politiciens la petite
pauline ça c'était ça n'était pas la
petite politique la polémique non parce
qu'il était normal de réagir écoutez
c'est encore normal mais on puisse faire
réagir et dire que
l'appartenance à l'union européenne et
nous sommes un parti pro-européen je
dire ne n'est pas reniement de la france
et donc nous avions besoin d'avoir les
deux drapeaux voilà mes tests simples
que cela valérie pécresse pour entrer
dans la stratégie pré présidentielle
elle semble courir pardon de lièvres à
la fois c'est pas très joli comme
formule maintenant un électorat parti
chez emmanuel macron et un autre parti
chez moi elle envoie des signes ou non
par exemple sur l'europe on ne savait
plus très bien souhaité non bien sûr que
si vous le savez très bien elle dénonce
les traités on sait plus ah bah oui mais
attendez ce n'est pas
sûr ce n'est pas être anti européen
c'est au contraire constructif si nous
avions eu un président de la république
qui soit au niveau sur la présidence
c'est cette présidence française
peut-être qu'il aurait pu faire comme
l'a fait nicolas sarkozy c'est à dire
faire le tour des capitales européennes
pour souvenez vous au moment de la de la
crise la crise financière de 2008
lorsque nicolas sarkozy à l'initiative
pour mettre en place processus de
stabilisation qui permet afin qu'ils
évitent que le système bancaire
s'effondrent comme il a pu s'effondrer
aux états unis il le fait pas coups de
provocations mais en allant faire le
tour des capitales européennes les unes
après les autres là sur le sujet de
l'immigration
le président de la république pouvait
très bien être à l'initiative en faisant
ce tour des capitales auront d'ailleurs
sétif sur l'europe on va écouter il est
dans le verbe comme à chaque fois il
fait des phrases on a
mais on a revu les tontons flingueurs il
ya deux jours voilà ces gens qui ont
l'habitude de faire des phrases parce
que sera capable d'agir
il faut quel rôle c'est non mais c'est
mara qui ont fait d'habitude de faire
des phrases c'est vraiment ça il fait
des phrases et il est dans la provoc
parce qu'il est incapable de faire à
l'etang-salé ipcress dit elle conteste
le la primauté du droit européen sur la
constitution nationale est-ce que c'est
pas faire des phrases parce que dans le
fond non parce qu'en font les traités
européens ils ont été votées par les
parlements par des parlements et donc
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire eh bien il
faut faire évoluer les arrêter sortir
des traités mais bien entendu mais mais
c'est reconstruire non non c'est
reconstruire à traiter mais comme sur
schengen aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a un
système de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine qui fonctionne non et donc
effectivement il faut passer par une
réforme de schengen et reconstruire les
choses encore un exemple précis sur
le fait de faire des phrases et la
réalité du travail voyez sur les
dépenses publiques emmanuel macron a dit
qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques lorsque nicolas sarkozy après
la crise de 2008 tu es président de la
république après cette crise violente de
2008 financière les dépenses publiques
augmentent de 1% par an avec françois
hollande on passe à 1,4 avec emmanuel
macron il ya aucune crise on est avant
la qu'ovide à 2,6 pour cent
d'augmentation de la dépense publique
le seul budget qui a été ou au on a fait
baisser les dépenses publiques vous
souvenez qui a été mise du budget en
2011 ne le répèterai saint-just oui mais
j'ai envers elle l a fait je voudrais
l'a pas été dans les français étaient
dans l'axé justement à propos de valérie
pécresse la présidente il veut à présent
dû faire elle elle le veut réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires de 200000 l
encre et 50000 mais elle veut réduire le
nombre de postes de fonctionnaires de
200 milles où ses brûlots ne met rien en
figaro qui disait qu'elle nous dise où
la question est pendant
vous êtes des des réponses très simple
j'étais maire pendant dix sept ans
lorsque vous recruter un agent de la
fonction publique dans une collectivité
territoriale dans une mairie pendant 70
ans il a la charge du contribuable à peu
près c'est à dire 40 ans d'activité 20
ans de retraite 10 ans de pension de
réversion c'est à peu près ça
demain si on oblige plus à recruter sous
le statut de la fonction publique pour
ceux qui rentreraient dans la fonction
publique sera contrat de droit privé
celle vous permet de faire des
restructurations quand vous faites des à
terre comme vous dites dans les mairies
par exemple on ne tombe d'abord vous
dites une partie des collectivités bien
sûr il ya deux
fonctions publiques le maire qu'avec
avait été maire de provins pendant si
longtemps et s'est ainsi attaché à ce
mandat qui dit ce seront les maires qui
devront supprimer des postes de
fonctionnaires pour nom pour embaucher
des gens ça sur un statut de droit privé
c'est simplement de dire quand vous
recrutez un maçon ou un plombier dans
une mairie un toutes les mairies ont des
maçons des plombiers enfin les mairies
d'une certaine taille est ce qu'il y a
besoin qu'ils soient à la charge de la
du contribuable de la ville pendant 70
ans je dis tout simplement ce maçon
plombier fait le même travail que s'il
travaille chez l'artisan du coin et à
partir de ce moment là quand vous êtes
en statut de droit privé et que vous
avez une intercommunalité vous vous
regroupez on peut passer effectivement
sur un statut de droit privé qui vous
évite d'un dépenses publiques quand dans
la dans la fonction publique d'état pour
prendre sur l'effort de sécurité des
pins sera la même sinon parce qu'à vous
permet de restructurer ce que totalement
différent on ne change rien pour ce
qu'ils sont et parler des retraites cet
art oui et non je vais vous prendre un
autre exemple sur jour là sur les deux
cent mille il y en a combien c'est
important parce que là on est bien dans
le même sens il ya combien de valérie
pécresse van gaal va vous le détailler
je pourrais encore pris jeu je vous
prends un autre exemple sur la
surveillance des bâtiments publics par
exemple aujourd'hui cette surveillance
des bâtiments publics se fait bien
souvent par des gendarmes dans fonction
publique d'état est ce que demain ça ne
peut pas être une société privée qui
fait la surveillance des bâtiments
publics vous confiez bien votre argent
des transports de fonds qui sont privées
et ça ça permet de remettre des
policiers et des gendarmes dans la rue
c'est à dire sur leur mission première
de sécurité que sur la surveillance de
bâtiments publics et on peut trouver
ainsi un certain nombre d'exemples qui
permet de réduire la dépense publique on
ne baissera pas les impôts si on ne
baisse pas la dépense publique quand
emmanuel macron dit j'ai baissé les
impôts il ment il augmente les
prélèvements obligatoires donc faut
arrêter de se fiche du monde elle a
regardé ce qui compte l'impôt sur le
revenu oui mais non non non c'est pas ça
qui dit il dit j'ai baissé les impôts il
ment une fois de plus la réalité pour
les français c'est ce qui sort de votre
poche ce qui sort de votre poche sont
les prélèvements obligatoires en tout
cas cette pro donc il a augmenté de
suppression de 200 milles diminution de
la dépense publique et de si vous voulez
baisser les impôts vous le voulez mais
la candidate votre candidate la
maintiendra telle quelle cette
proposition n'est pas question de
revenir dessus il faut diminuer la
dépense publique pour l'imac s il a des
portes écoutez bien évidemment que non
il n'est pas question de revenir dessus
simplement de préciser néanmoins voilà
mais ça va être fait ça va être fait et
on le fera je veux dire de manière
intelligente c'est à dire de ne pas
toucher à la qualité du service public
l'exemple que je vous prenez dans une
mairie tout à l'heure il est très
concret ça ne change rien sur la qualité
du service public sur la surveillance
des bâtiments c'est la même chose qui
fait que le jour où vous n'avez plus
besoin de surveiller un bâtiment public
basse est une société privée vous ne
passez plus de contrat avec s'est
terminée faire c'est une dépense
publique qui diminue valérie pécresse
pour se qualifier au second tour doit
évidemment faire la différence avec
marine le pen zemmour dans les derniers
sondages elle est au même niveau on
verra ce que donne les sondages après la
d entretien des manuels macron
comment fait elle comment fait-elle pour
faire la différence adresses en france
nationaliste il est très puissant oui
mais si tu devais l'herbe
c'est pas de cette manière dont on fait
la différence en convainquant les
français c'est ce n'est pas en se
positionnant par rapport à tel ou tel
autre candidat ça n'est pas notre sujet
c'est de répondre aux attentes des
français d'être capable leur proposer un
projet est l'exemple que je vous donnais
sur valérie pécresse tout à l'heure sur
le budget la seule ministre du budget
qui a réussi à faire baisser la dépense
publique ce n'est pas rien ça montre la
capacité à faire les choses lorsqu elle
est présidente de la région ile de
france a fait baisser les dépenses de
fonctionnement de 10 % j'ai pas le
sentiment que les franciliens se soit
plaint de la manière dont elle exerçait
sa présidence de la région ile de france
puisqu'ils l'ont réélu donc c'est bien
qu'ils lui ont fait confiance et
d'autres présidents de droite laurent
wauquiez a fait la même chose c'est là
la différence entre monsieur macron qui
fait des phrases et nous qui avons un
certain nombre de personnalités qui ont
la capacité à mener des grandes régions
qui ont demain tu n'as pas si des
récettes diriger la france emmanuel
macron sans vous préoccuper de marine le
pen qui s'est toujours préoccupé des
français aussi en cas pas si ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas de cibler emmanuel
macron c'est de répondre aux attentes
des français et d'avoir les cours s'il
s'agissait tibet oui m'enfin attendait
la séquence c'est pas ça qui fait cette
interview qui cherche à faire la provoc
c'est bien le président de la république
qui le fait de manière politicienne
c'est bien ça sur nos gammes ya la
question christian jacob
vous avez un local de campagne à votre
candidate est une équipe grande équipe
elle est paritaire fou quand même
répondre à ça a dit valérie pécresse est
pas du tout paris terre c'est du simple
au double j'ai compté oui j'ai compté
chez les rouges
c'est du simple au double mais la moitié
des femmes il ya moins de deux fois
moins de femmes que d'hommes alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a tenu à dire
que tu es paritaire est par ailleurs et
ça je fais une erreur sur le fond non
mais j'imagine que peut-être que
l'organigramme est pas complet je serai
jugé pas d'être mangés ben alors ce sera
larmes espagnoles si il ya déjà 100
personnes ce week-end mexico mexique non
mais cela dit c'était pas important
d'être paritaire aujourd'hui alors
qu'elle est candidate femme et qu'elle
en a fait d'ailleurs des sept premiers
mots après son élection le 4 décembre
elle a dit vous avez une femme quelle
audace à tous adhérents et là elle fait
une équipe qui n'est pas du tout pareil
terre écouté paroles de son nom mais bon
c'est pas ça mais j'ai du coup et
honnêtement vous savez on a passé trois
nuits sur les répliques voilà sur le
passé ni terre et ses terres non
monsieur bel bien sûr que non que ces
panneaux da mais je pense que si elle le
dit c'est que l'équipe l'ait et sans
doute qu'il ya vraisemblablement
un certain nombre de personnalités qui
figurent pas dedans qui sont dans
l'équipe parce que je suis a dit que
c'est paritaire c'est que ça paritaire
voilà merci qui merci
malgré la fatigue
sur lci